the refugee crisis and expenses related
to it are to be considered extraordinary
circumstances the Commission is going to
look at it on a case-by-case basis
depending on the real expenditures that
countries are making but there is a
consensus that this bridge financing
should be done by national credit lines
i would say that we have now a political
agreement on how these national credit
lines should function and the caffeine
has mandated the european working group
and UFC a group to finalize this
agreement for the next echofon in
december we have agreed in the Mandate
of the echofon for the climate change
conference in paris cop21 I think that
the mandate that the echofon has given
has to be seen in complementarity with
the mandate that if environment
ministers have been given in parallel
with this agreement the European Union
is playing its role as one of the main
drivers of this conference the EU
remains committed to contributing its
fair share to international commitment
of mobilizing 100 billion u.s. dollars
in climate finance per year per by 2020
today ministers also discussed the
future of the economic and monetary unit
ministers welcomes the Commission's
ongoing work to make the European
semester more transparent and less
complex while not weakening the
stability and growth pact however the
euro area moves forward it must do so in
an open and transparent way in a way
that does not create barriers for those
member states not in the euro area in
the way which respect the integrity of
the single marked at the end of the day
a successful EMU is
in the interest of all EU member states